من اثيوبيا حيث قال المتحدث مثل الخارجيه
الاثيركيه
ان نهر النيل نهر افريقي ويجب حل الخلافات
بشانه في البيت الافريقي وطالب بوقف احاله
ملف سد النهضه الى مجلس الامن الدولي او
الجامعه العربيه واكد المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه ان بلاده مستمره في استكمال بناء
سد النهضه مشيرا الى ان الهدف من ذلك هو
تحقيق مشاريعها التنمويه وتوفير الكهرباء
ل 65 مليون اثيوبي يعيشون في الظلام وقال
انما وصفها بالاتفاقات الاستعماريه
السابقه هي اتفاقات قديمه ولن تقبل بها
اثيوبيا من نادي سببا ينضموا الينا مدير
مكتب الجزيره محمد طه توكل اذا كان محمد
طه متحدث باسم خارجيه يقول بان هذا الملف
يجب ان يدرس في اطار البيت الافريقي ما هي
الافكار التي تطرحها اثيوبيا لطمانه
الجانب المصري والسوداني ايضا
نعم مع عبد الصمد هذا الملف طبعا ترحل
كثيرا بين الامم المتحده وبين الدول
الثلاثه
وملف انتقل الى رئيس الدوره السابقه
للاتحاد الافريقي ولكن مجلس الامن الدولي
اعاد الملف الى الاتحاد الافريقي وحتى هذه
اللحظه
اللجنه الرئاسيه يعني انتقل الملف من رئيس
الكونغو ثم الى رئيس النقال الان الى رئيس
جزر القمر ولازال الملف يتراوح مكانته
ولكن البلدان الثلاثه ايضا
حدثت بينهم تباينات كثيره ومؤخرا تم
الاتفاق بين السودان واثيوبيا لايجاد حل
هذا الملف من خلال قمه رئيس الوزراء لسبي
ورئيس مجلس السياده وبالتالي كما قال قبل
قليل المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الاثيوبيه هو
الرد على هذا الملف لان هذا الملف كان
مسكوت عنه الطول عام 2022 البلدان الثلاثه
لم يكونوا يعلق على هذا الملف تسريحات
وزير الخارجيه المصري
التي
اشار في اجتماع مجلس الوزراء العرب خطوره
سد النهضه قال ملس علم اليوم ان هذا
التصريح كان بالنسبه لنا مفاجي في حاله
هناك كانت في حوارات في وسطات في اتصالات
ولا زالت في قنوات بيننا ولكن تصريح وزير
الخارجيه كان بالنسبه لنا سادب وهو ما
قاله ملس الم عبد الصمد هو تاكيد للتمسك
اثيوبيا للحلول الافريقيه وان يحل الى هذا
هذا الملف في البيت الافريقي وايضا اكد
استمراريه بناء السد وقال يجب ان يحل هذا
الملف في اطار الحوار الثلاثي بين البلدان
الثلاثه فبالتالي هو تسعيد جديد يسبق طبعا
التعبئه الرابعه المتوقعه في يونيو القادم
طبعا تدفق المياه يعني عبد الصمد يعني هو
من اجل بناء
اضافات في السد النهضه عبد الصمد